Cuando voy a una escuela y hablo con los estudiantes,
siempre les pregunto lo mismo:
¿Por qué googlean?
¿Por qué escogen Google como su motor de búsqueda?
Extraño y todo, siempre dan las mismas 3 respuestas.
Uno: "Porque funciona",
que es una gran respuesta; por eso yo también googleo.
Dos: --alguno dirá--
"No conozco ninguna otra alternativa".
No es una respuesta igual de buena y siempre respondo diciendo:
"Intenten googlear 'motor de búsqueda',
puede que encuentren un par de alternativas interesantes".
Y por último, pero no menos importante:
inevitablemente, un estudiante levantará la mano y dirá:
"Con Google, estoy seguro de que siempre obtendré el resultado más imparcial".
Seguro de que siempre obtendré el resultado más imparcial.
Como hombre de humanidades,
aunque hombre de humanidades digitales,
esto me eriza la piel,
aunque también veo que esa confianza, la creencia en el resultado imparcial,
es una piedra angular de nuestro amor colectivo y del valor que damos a Google.
Les mostraré por qué, filosóficamente, eso es casi un imposible.
Pero déjenme primero profundizar, solo un poco, en un principio básico
que hay detrás de toda consulta y que algunas veces parece que olvidamos.
Cuando vayan a googlear,
empiece preguntándose lo siguiente: "¿Busco un hecho aislado?".
¿Cuál es la capital de Francia?
¿Cuáles son los componentes básicos de una molécula de agua?
Listo, googleelo.
No hay un grupo de científicos que estén a punto de probar
que en realidad es Londres y H30.
Uno no ve una gran conspiración en esas cosas.
Estamos de acuerdo, a escala global,
sobre cuáles son las respuestas a estos hechos aislados.
Pero si uno complica la consulta un poco y pregunta, por ejemplo:
"¿Por qué hay un conflicto entre Israel y Palestina?".
Entonces, ya no busca un hecho particular,
uno busca conocimiento,
que es algo mucho más complicado y delicado.
Y para llegar al conocimiento,
hay que poner 10, 20 o 100 hechos sobre la mesa
y reconocerlos y decir: "Sí, son todos ciertos."
Pero al ser lo que soy, joven o viejo, negro o blanco, gay o heterosexual,
los valoraré de manera diferente.
Y diré: "Sí, esto es cierto,
pero esto es más importante para mí que aquello".
Y en este punto es que se vuelve interesante,
porque es ahí donde nos volvemos humanos.
Ahí es cuando empezamos a discutir, a ser sociedad.
Para llegar realmente a alguna parte, necesitamos filtrar todos los hechos,
a través de amigos, vecinos, padres, niños,
compañeros de trabajo y periódicos y revistas,
y así finalmente estar basados en un conocimiento real,
algo en lo que poco puede ayudar un motor de búsqueda.
Les prometí un ejemplo solo para mostrar por qué es tan difícil
llegar al punto de verdadero conocimiento limpio, objetivo,
como alimento del pensamiento.
Llevaré a cabo un par de consultas simples, consultas de búsqueda.
Vamos a empezar con "Michelle Obama"
la Primera Dama de EE. UU.
Y vamos a buscar por imágenes.
Funciona muy bien, como se puede ver.
Es un resultado de búsqueda perfecto, más o menos.
Solo está ella en la foto, ni siquiera el Presidente.
¿Cómo funciona esto?
Bastante sencillo.
Google lo hace con mucha inteligencia, pero es algo bastante sencillo,
reparan en dos cosas antes que nada.
Primero, ¿cuál es la leyenda a pie de foto en cada sitio web?
¿Dice "Michelle Obama" a pie de foto?
Bastante buena indicación de que en realidad ella está allí.
Segundo, Google explora en el archivo de imagen,
el nombre del archivo subido a la página web.
¿Se llama "MichelleObama.jpeg"?
Buena señal de que Clint Eastwood no está en la foto.
Uno tiene esos criterios y se obtiene un resultado de búsqueda como este. Casi.
En 2009, Michelle Obama fue víctima de una campaña racista,
donde la gente empezó a insultarla a través de resultados de búsqueda.
Había una imagen distribuida ampliamente a través de Internet
con su cara distorsionada para que pareciera un mono.
Y esa foto fue publicada por todas partes.
Y la gente la publicó muy a propósito,
para llegar hasta allí en los resultados de búsqueda.
Se aseguraron de escribir "Michelle Obama" en la foto
y se aseguraron de cargar la imagen como 'MichelleObama.jpeg' o similares.
Uds. entienden por qué, para manipular el resultado de búsqueda.
Y funcionó, también.
Así que cuando se googleaba 'Michelle Obama' por imágenes en 2009,
esa imagen distorsionada como mono aparecía entre los primeros resultados.
Los resultados son de autolimpieza,
y eso es parte de belleza de esto,
porque Google mide la relevancia cada hora, cada día.
Sin embargo, Google no se conformó esta vez,
pensaron: "Eso es racista y un mal resultado de búsqueda
y vamos a limpiar esto manualmente.
Escribiremos algo de código para arreglarlo".
Lo hicieron.
Y no creo que nadie aquí crea que haya sido una mala idea.
Yo tampoco.
Pero un par de años más tarde,
lo más googleado del mundo fue Anders,
Anders Behring Breivik,
quien hizo lo que hizo.
El 22 de julio en 2011,
un terrible día en la historia de Noruega.
Este hombre, un terrorista, voló un par de edificios del gobierno
a poca distancia de donde estamos ahora en Oslo, Noruega,
y luego viajó a la isla de Utoya
y disparó y mató a un grupo de niños.
Casi 80 personas murieron ese día.
Y un montón de gente describiría este acto de terror como dos pasos,
que hizo dos cosas: hizo explotar los edificios y disparó a esos niños.
No es verdad.
Fueron tres pasos.
Hizo explotar esos edificios, disparó a esos niños,
y se sentó y esperó a que el mundo lo googleara.
Y preparó los tres pasos igualmente bien.
Y si hubo alguien que inmediatamente entendió esto,
fue un desarrollador sueco de webs,
un experto en motores de búsqueda de Estocolmo, llamado Nikke Lindqvist.
También es un hombre muy político
y estaba bien en las redes sociales, en su blog y en Facebook.
Y dijo a todo el mundo,
"Si hay algo que este tipo quiere en este momento,
es controlar su propia imagen.
Veamos si podemos distorsionar eso.
Veamos si nosotros, el mundo civilizado, podemos protestar contra lo que hizo
insultándolo en sus resultados de búsqueda".
¿Y cómo?
Dijo a todos sus lectores lo siguiente:
"Busquen en Internet,
encuentren fotos de caca de perro en las aceras
encuentren fotos de caca de perro en las aceras,
publíquenlas en sus feeds, en sus sitios web, en sus blogs.
Asegúrense de escribir el nombre del terrorista en la imagen,
asegúrese de nombrar el archivo de imagen así 'Breivik.jpeg'.
Enseñemos a Google que ese es el rostro del terrorista".
Y funcionó.
Dos años después de la campaña contra Michelle Obama,
funcionó esta campaña de manipulación contra Anders Behring Breivik.
Al googlear por imágenes de él semanas tras lo acaecido el 22 de julio en Suecia,
se verían imágenes de la caca de perro arriba de los resultados de búsqueda,
como una pequeña protesta.
Por extraño que parezca, Google no intervino en esta ocasión.
No intervino y no limpió manualmente los resultados de búsqueda.
Así la pregunta del millón es
¿hay algo diferente entre estos dos acontecimientos?
¿Hay algo diferente entre lo que pasó con Michelle Obama
y lo que le pasó con Anders Behring Breivik?
Por supuesto que no.
Es exactamente lo mismo,
sin embargo, Google intervino en un caso y no en el otro.
¿Por qué?
Debido a que Michelle Obama es una persona honorable, por eso,
y Anders Behring Breivik es una persona despreciable.
¿Ven lo que pasa?
Se evalúa a una persona
y solo hay un poder en el mundo
con autoridad para decidir quién es quién.
"Le gusta, le disgusta.
Creemos en ti, no creemos en ti.
Tienes razón, te equivocas. Eres verdad, eres falso.
Tú eres Obama y tú Breivik".
Ese es poder sin igual.
Por eso les recuerdo que detrás de cada algoritmo
hay siempre una persona,
una persona con un conjunto de creencias personales
que ningún código puede erradicar completamente.
Y mi mensaje va no solo a Google,
sino a todos los creyentes en la fe de código del mundo.
Es necesario identificar su propio sesgo personal.
Es necesario comprender que uno es humano
y, en consecuencia, asumir la responsabilidad
Y digo esto porque creo que hemos llegado a un punto
en que es absolutamente imperativo
atar esos lazos de nuevo, de forma más ajustada:
las humanidades y la tecnología.
Más apretados que nunca.
Y para recordarnos que esa idea maravillosamente seductora
del resultado de búsqueda limpio imparcial
es, y probable siga siendo, un mito.
Gracias por tu tiempo.
(Aplausos)